[Music]
okay it's a pleasure to introduce Jean
fris Bas from the University of of South
Florida and he has made the trip over
here from Seattle um this afternoon
where he is attending the qip conference
and he is uh so friendly to give a talk
to us as well about his work uh which we
are really interested in because it it
relates to uh the work on post Quantum
cryptography that we're doing in that it
uh looks at algorithms to solve certain
problems that we think or hope are uh
difficult so without further Ado uh
welcome and well thanks thanks for the
introduction I don't know if I need the
microphone I mean it's on but yeah it's
yeah so I'm just going to put it aside
yeah so um so yeah I I want to present a
few um some of my recent work on on
Quantum algorithms and why and why and
and and especially those that you know
have some kind of you know that pertain
to cryptography so but first you know
you it Cann you can hardly talk about
postcon cryptography without reminding
you
know you know without being aware that
you know we're all there doing post
cryptography because uh it has been
shown that there was a way to build a
Quon computer that would solve U that
with Factor integers and solve the
discret L po poal time and and of course
the reason why it's it's really um it's
really concerning is that most of our um
most of our public key uh crypto crypto
systems that are currently deployed they
either rely on on RSA which is
essentially um um energer factoring or
the disc problem so if we don't want our
postquantum world to look look like on
the one hand you know the the desperate
users and evil entities uh having a a
quantum computer and being able to crack
you know basically all the keys then you
need to think of
Alternatives so alternatives to um RSA
based crypto systems and and DLP based
crypto systems and there are I mean I
wouldn't say I don't want to say there
are alternatives there's been a lot of
serious proposals for Alterna to um to
the the to the currently deployed uh
public key crypto systems so that
includes uh latus based crypto systems
uh what they call multivariate
cryptography so relying on the hardness
of finding solutions to systems of
polyal equations code based cryptography
where you may basically use M crypto
system uh with some random codes and you
hope that um that will be intractable an
an adversary isogen based cryptography
is something that I'm I'm going to say
something about uh during this talk it
it's it's of interest to the people in
Microsoft so probably they some of them
probably know more than me about the
subject but I think it's I mean what I'm
going to talk about is quantum
algorithms that relate to the security
of of these
schemes so um I would like to so what I
I want to present Quantum algorithm I
think it's really important when you
talk about postquantum cryptography to
really look at the quantum algorithms uh
and so I meant that talk to be a you
know to not assume too much knowledge
about um quum algorithms so what can we
what can we say from a very high level
perspective about uh Quantum
algorithms well a cubit can be many
things um so well I will say that in my
case a cubit will be a
cat in a
box okay and the box has a
door and the Box Inside the Box there's
some kind of string that's going to
inject the cat with either Placebo or
some kind of poison and and whether it
does you know if inject the cat with
poison of placebo is some randomized
process and and a Quantum and the
quantum state of of this whole thing is
well it's like a it encapsulates the
probability that the cat is dead versus
the cat is alive okay I mean it's it's
it's a formalism that was introduced by
shringer uh as one way of looking at a
Quantum system and well so what can I do
well I can do all sorts of things to
this system I mean okay that one is not
very interesting has only one cubit but
you can do many things and then
ultimately you're going to measure it
and and here a measurement can be for
you know can be described as opening the
door and checking whether the cat is
alive or dead so you go from a situation
where the cat has say a probability
Alpha uh to be
dead and 1 minus Alpha to be
alive so you describe the state by those
power booies essentially you say well
you know the the power the cat is in
this you know alpha alpha
sorry Alpha Dead 1 minus Alpha alive
sort of stay and once you open the door
you can actually check that the cat is
dead or alive and which collapses the
the system into a new uh a new a a new
Quantum state where that that time it's
if it's dead then it's 100% chance dead
0% chance alive okay so we're going to
see a little bit later like how later in
the talk how really um the quantum
states are massaged through Quantum
algorithms but before I get there I want
to say that you know dealing with only
one cube is not necessarily very
interesting so a two cubic system could
be you know two cats each in their own
box okay and then well then you know you
have this phenomena of you know like how
those two how those two elements of your
system interact with each other so if if
your system is just a direct product it
means basically that the two cats are
you know things that are happening to
those two cats are completely
independent which means you open the
door here you'll see what happened to
that cat and has no influence on on that
one and that in that case we say that
this is a direct product of of those two
components but they can also be
entangled which means for example one
one very simple way of having
entanglement in that system of cat in
boxes to say well imagine that those
Stranges that inject the the cat or
injecting it with probably Alpha and
oneus Alpha but injecting each cat with
the same thing in that case you open the
door here to check the state of that cat
it will tell you everything that cat but
also that one because you know they've
been injected with the same thing okay
and that collapses the entire thing into
a new state where cat is 100% dead or Al
so now the the interesting question is
how do we um manipulate Quantum States
okay that's that's really the important
part with a Quantum
algorithm but before I get there um so
before I get there I want to I want to
present that General sort of formalism
for the algorithms that are of interest
for us so there are many ways of of
describing Quantum algorithms but
there's people noticed that the a lot of
the problems in computational number
theory that are of interest to
cryptography could be uh could be made
part of the same sort of framework where
they're rephrased in as the problem of
finding a subgroup a hidden subgroup and
the way um the way you would formulate
it very precisely is assuming you have a
function from R to the m to a bunch of
quantum States okay remember Quantum
States could be my cats but you know it
could be Al all sorts of physical
systems and and such that the function
hides a discrete subgroup of R to the m
and hiding it means that your subgroup
is the periods of your function so your
your function Cycles back every time it
hits an element of your secret
subgroup and and that means and so and
first of all of course you have to
rephrase your problem in terms of
finding you know solving my problem has
to uh Rel has to
um has to boil down to finding this
secret discrete subgroup G okay and so
the most I mean important problem I mean
the most important uh hidden HSP based
Quantum algorithm for cryptographers is
of course shes algorithm okay factoring
an RSA number in polyal time and the way
it works well it has a it uses the
quantum algorithm kind of like is a CO
processor there's a little part of that
algorithm that's actually completely
classical so what it does is well given
n whose factorization is unknown find a
co-prime number with n note that failing
at finding a co-prime element to n is
essentially solving your problem so that
search is certainly not a problem and
then you would like to have an R such
that a to the r R so you want to yeah
sorry let R be the order of a m n okay
and then if R happens to be even you
have this okay which means uh which
means basically that knowing R will give
you an equation of the form um x
-1 uh x + 1 equals 0 mod n or the
product of two things being divisible by
n okay and with good and with with good
enough probability this will give you a
non-trivial factor of n not all the time
okay but but you know it you repeat the
experiment if it does not and here is
the function that will hide your
subgroup so first of all what is the
subgroup you're looking for well you're
looking at the subgroup of Z defined by
RZ okay R is the order of a mud n
knowing R essentially allows you to
write down equation of this form and
most of the time I mean not most of the
time with a constant probability it will
get you a nonrival constant Factor so
you want to find R given a and so that
is the same as finding RZ given a and
then your function could be expressed in
this way you start from Z and you uh
associate a to the X Mod n and then you
encode that in some way
quantumly okay and then every time you
hit an element that's a multiple of the
order of your um of a then it will reset
right because a to the r is congruent to
one mod n that's definition of R being
the order of a mud n so what it means is
that you have exactly the right property
to your function you know that your
function hides the subgroup RZ of Z
solving the
HP formulated with this function here
will essentially give you a non-trivial
factor of of your number so so that's
how that's not how C that's not how it
was originally described but it's
clearly uh how it can be made into this
uh you know fit into this General
framework of of hidden sub
problem so um now what does a computer
quantum computer do well so here's the
thing uh Quantum States they're
described by vectors in C to the 2 to
the C to the 2 to the N okay where n is
the number of
cubits um so and it gives you basically
uh each coordinate is essentially the
probability of being in a certain State
okay so two to the N there are two to
the N different states for example here
with one cat n equals 2 okay uh sorry um
n equals 1 and there are two possible
States then you have two cats n equals 2
and then there are four possible States
so you would you would describe this uh
Quantum system as a vector of two Co um
sorry Vector four coordinat and each
coordinate Will describe the probability
of being in a certain state so of course
as such the sum of those probability
have to be one now what's funny and what
allows um really interesting things to
happen is that the the coefficients are
in C and not in in in R so the
probabilities are complex so what you're
saying that they all sum to one because
the probability of measuring a certain a
certain um value is this okay so
absolute value of of the coordinate I uh
Square so that's the probability of
getting I in in this vector when you
measure when you measure the the quantum
system now when you when you have a a
Quantum algorithm what it does is it
it's the same I mean for each Quantum
algorithm basically you you could you
could have a unitary Matrix in C to the
2 the n * 2 the n and then it takes the
input State here I call it f you
multiply it so remember Quantum States
they're just vectors so you can multiply
it's just a
Matrix Vector multiplication gives you a
new Vector which describes the new
probabilities of being in you know all
the possible outcomes of a measurement
and as long as so and this is of course
an Infinity of of potential unitaries
and then basically that's how you can
modelize your um uh Quantum algorithms
Quantum algorithm and so that's what a
Quantum circuit looks like because
usually instead of having
unitary uh in one go you know if you
want to implement a Quantum algorithm
what you want to have is a circuit just
like um just like the classical
computers they have um I mean you know
you could have all sorts of circuits but
the way you would actually do it is you
want to break it down into a set of like
an Universal set of gates like you know
nand for example and then rewrite you
know have your manufacturer only only
work on a very restricted set of of of
of logical Gates and then you want to
you want to build your circuit of a very
small set of gates so in in um in the
quantum in Quantum in Quantum
algorithms you know even though you know
the circuits can all be uh you know
arbitrary unitaries then there are ways
to rewrite those unitaries in terms of
say for example um Clifford plus the T
Gates okay so that's like a universal
set of gates and and then you know it
will look like something like this and
then at the end so you start with an
input State you'll get an output State
and then you measure and you hope that
that measurement will give you your the
answer to your problem usually What will
What happen what's going to happen is
the measurement will not necessarily
give it to you it will give it to you
with good probability is usually what
happens because remember a lot of the
things here are
probabilistic so as far as the HSP is
concerned one main ingredient is what
they call the quantum free transform so
that's this ugly State and another one
is uh if you know a circuit for the
function f that hides your your discrete
subgroup of R to the N you're going to
apply to this state and you get this
funny double sum here and then so oh I
don't like double sums they they freak
me out but what what what what is this
well it's it's um a sum of many
different vectors and what happens when
you measure it so here they're Quantum
encodings of of vectors and you sum over
all possible vectors in in a certain
region of of of the the hyper you know
of of Z to the k um so what happens is
when you measure you'll get a vector
okay so now your vector has to answer
your PO in in in some way and it turns
out that what works really what what
makes it work is the phase here when
this dot product here is close to one
then when you carry on the computations
you can see that that your probability
of measurements of X is high which means
is what what it means is these y's are
in the lattice that you're trying to
construct and the fact that x * Y is
close to an integer means in fact that
you're hitting um a vector in the dual
lce so what happens when you make this
measurement here on on this Quantum
state is that you can prove you know
once once you carry on the computation
of probabilities of drawing a certain X
in Z subn to the K is that you're you're
going to be more likely to draw vectors
that are in the Dual lattice so
basically you create those States and
then you measure those States and
hopefully you get vectors in the Dual
lce okay
now what does it have to do with
anything well the Dual lce it's exactly
what you get when you solve sh's
algorithm I mean for those of you guys
who who who see shs algorithm like the
original description you know they'll
tell you well what you want to find is R
but what you really find is a multiple
of one / r that and that's how it's
phrased and then you you reconstruct it
by you know uh looking at a um continued
fraction expansion but what really what
what's happened finding a multiple of
one over R really is finding a an
element in the Dual lattice of a
one-dimensional lattice generated by the
vector R you know that one coordinate so
it's all about measuring vectors and
hoping that they're close enough to the
Dual of the lattice and then using
classical techniques to go from the Dual
lattice to the actual lattice that you
you're trying to I mean that will
hopefully answer your problem so discret
lock problem also uh formulate can also
be formulated in terms of
a hidden subgroup
problem so um now moving on to um more
uh number
Theory the so that k a number field o
the maxim order class group just the
fractional ideals Coti by the principal
ideals so it's not really important
actually I left it there but what's
really interesting here is that problem
the What's called the principle idea
problem so so given uh an input ideal
usually my ideals would be with Gothic
letters so let's say you're looking at
an ideal in the maximum order of a
number field the principal ideal problem
consists of deciding whether or not
you're looking at a principal ideal and
if so finding a generator okay which
will be just a field element now what
does it have to do with anything you
know regarding uh
cryptography Well turns out there
there's been a series of recent work
that show that in fact if you do have an
oracle for finding generators of
principal ideals then you're can
threaten the security of of of some
lattice-based crypto systems so there's
one so one family of of of Lattis based
crypto systems it relies just precisely
on the hardness of of finding a short
generator of a principal ideal so and
these include
so multi-linear Maps uh some candidates
for multi-linear maps so multi-linear
Maps they allow you to do some like a
discrete the D Hine key exchange um
protocol with more than two people so so
people were got excited with that the
other thing that it uh allows you to do
is people notice that there was some
meability in that form of encryption and
then you could do some fully homomorphic
encryption
schemes and also and that really didn't
go well some people thought oh because
there's lates involved chances are it
could also be um post Quantum so Quantum
safe so that really didn't go well
because turns out uh in some recent work
ker Dua Baker and and regf what they
they did is they showed that that this
problem of finding a short generator of
a principal ideal in fact reduces poly
and classically to the problem of
finding some generator at least in some
settings which was the relevant setting
for cryptography that's psychic fields
of of of a power conductor of power of
two so exually the fields that were used
in
cryptography so solving the PIP it gives
you you know after that you can you can
attack it in in poly time and so if you
solve the pi the principal your problem
in polyal time with the quantum computer
then you have a poly time attack against
well pretty much everything you can
think of that relates on the short on
the hardness of finding a short gener a
principle ideal so so that's certainly
that certainly was a little um
concerning now now people are like Okay
can this also um help you find short
vectors in lates that are just you know
ideals and but not necessarily principal
so it turns out that the shortest gener
the shortest generator of principal
ideal is a
shorsh vector in your ideal and by that
I I mean it's a solution to gamma SVP so
gamma SVP is the shortest Vector problem
with approximation Factor gamma okay so
you know if you can solve that with
short gamma then clearly you you're
threatening the the security of of L is
based crypto system and then when gamma
is a little bigger well in this case the
shortest generator of a of a principal
ideal it's it's a solution for gamma VP
for an approximation gamma that that is
let's say um not very small but also not
completely large so it's it's worth
mentioning and it turns out that so in
general so first of all clearly that
means that gamma SVP will reduce to the
PIP in in this for this kind of
approximation factor and then in arit in
principal ideals for sure and in
arbitrary ideals you can also do it by
simply saying that you can find the
right multiple of your non-principal
idea to first you know push it into a
princi principal ideal and then deal
with that principal ideal so and that's
been done by CR it's another crummer
actually it's crer Dua and fovi for that
recent paper um so what's interesting
about it is that that means that if you
assume a Quantum polyal time algorithm
to to find generators of principal
ideals what it means is you have a
solution for gamma SVP for that
approximation Factor gamma in polyal
time why
classically uh bkz will will give you a
subexponential time complexity it's like
an exponential square root n type of
runtime so you have one of those highly
sought after super poal improvement over
the classical stateof the art and people
really like that when you come up with
an algorithm that works in poly time for
quum computers for a problem that no one
can seem to find a solution with you
know efficient solution ution with with
actual with regular computers and even
more interesting is that this is a
lattice problem so of course people are
very excited about whether or not lates
you know lattice problems can be solved
efficiently with Corum computers so that
that's an example but of course these
lates are highly structured so they're
many many butts and you know one of them
is that those um lates are highly
structured this General this
generalization is in fact
heuristic uh so there's a lot of caveats
but but still like people
were that that people found that
relevant to ltis based
cryptography now um here's how we do the
um we find our uh solutions to principal
ideal problem so finding generators of a
principal ideal we make a little detour
instead of tackling the problem of
directly we go through uh like a more
General thing which more General problem
which consists of finding the group of s
units for a certain um s of um a set of
prime ideals so an s unit given a set of
prime ideals it consists of finding the
group of X and K such that the
decomposition of the principal ideal
generated by X is a product of only
primes in the set of s is in set of
prime s so that's the s unit group okay
um and so the way so the way we did it
is by so by reducing that to the hidden
subgroup problem for which we know that
we can find efficient uh Quantum
Solutions so being an s unit means that
there is some kind of product of the pis
in s such that that ideal multiplied by
those pis is the trivial ideal and
that's how we're going to define a
function that hide this group of s units
by saying well take elements in this
horrible set um yeah and I'm not going
to be basically that that that is uh
made of of what you need to embed the
number field into R to the n and you
associate elements in this complicated
set to Lates and lates to Quantum States
and it turns out that when you do it
that way okay every time you hit a pair
that corresponds to the complex
embeddings of your s units and the
valuations of that s unit at the primes
then this thing is going to be trivial
and that's how that function basically
hides your s unit group so I'm not going
to spend too much time on that like
there was a little too many equations
but bottom line is you can hide the S
units okay with a function that
satisfies the good properties to be
called a hidden subgroup problem that
can be solved in poly time now once you
do that you may want to know how do I
reduce say my problem of finding a
generator in a principal ideal to uh and
the computation of a certain s unit
group so the way you do it is you take
your input ideal and you factor it um as
a product of prime
ideals and then the set of primes that
you're going to use when you compute
your I group is precisely the primes
that divide your input
ideal and then well your input ideal is
principle if and only
if it is sorry if and only
if it is uh it corresponds to the dec
composition of an s unit okay so to find
an s unit uh sorry to find is you first
find the s unit group and you know that
you know if your principal if the sorry
if the ideal you you gave your algorithm
as input is principal then it means that
it will be a principal ideal generated
by an s unit for that set s by
definition of the fact that we put in s
all the prime divisors of
a so then it just boys down to a simple
linear algebra uh system that you need
to solve where uh the unknowns are the
valuations at the prime so it's a very
simple sort of classical reduction aside
from that little factorization at the
beginning everything is essentially
classical so you're you're just looking
at at a linear system and it tells you
whether or not your your principal ideal
that you you you you you gave as inputs
I mean your ideal as given as input is
principal and if it and if it is it will
also give you the generator for the same
price okay so that's just to to say that
principal idea problem which we said was
important for some of the Ring based
crypto systems is in fact just um uh
just reduces to the s unit group problem
which itself is a hidden subgroup
problem now principle IDE your problem
is not really the only thing you can do
with that it turns out we had all sorts
of so we had all sorts of um I mean we
looked at all sorts of uh um um problems
in computational number theory that that
are not necessarily relevant to
cryptography so I'm not going to give a
lot of details in in that but on that
but you know Computing class groups and
unit groups uh these are one break class
groups another one um relative Norm
equations that that's actually nice
because it relates to the resolution I
mean the the P of of solving D equations
which is a a big problem and number
Theory so you have we have a a list of
of interesting problems in computation
number theory that can basically solved
by using the knowledge of ss units for
certain well chosen set s so it's not
just for cryptography that we were
looking at it and now I want to talk
about the hidden subware problem in a
non-ab bilion setting so in particular
another uh type of proposals that I that
I was mentioning at the very beginning
of the talk was I ogyny based crypto
systems and as we're going to see here I
mean there's a way of reformulating the
problem of finding and misogyny between
two curves as a hidden shift problem
which itself can be reformulated as a
hidden shift as a hien subgroup problem
but this time in this weird and a weird
semi-direct
product so I don't know exactly um how
much uh knowledge on misogyny and
misogyny based uh crypto system the
audience has uh is there anyone working
on it besides
you Patrick and then no one else well
well then it won't hurt because it's
happening so so um so as I said um we're
going to talk about isogeny based crypto
systems and I'm going to actually Define
how they work um so that's why I'm not
really assuming a lot of knowledge here
on on elliptic curves or isogenes or
anything so basically uh we're going to
show that we have an algorithm for
computing uh isogen between tic curves
and relies on identifying some weak
instances and searching for them so f is
a field and elliptic curve is is
basically um I mean the group of points
elliptic curves is basically solutions
to that and some points at Infinity okay
and um so I
mean the only thing that we need to pay
attention about in the definition is
that we are we have ordinary and super
singular elliptic curves and when it
comes down to the computation of
isogenes which I'm going to define a few
slides well it's really not the same so
you have two different types of elliptic
curves over finite fields and we'll see
that at some point when it comes down to
uh the security of of the schemes that
rely on the hardness of of of finding
isogenes between curves that will have
its
importance so as I said the group of
points of elliptic curves uh so the all
the the roots of that equation plus the
point on Infinity they're group so what
it means is there's this famous um uh
tangent and cord uh way of of of
calculating P plus Q you you know you
you you search for the third
intersection and then you you take this
symmetry is like
the yeah symmetry with respect to the
horizontal axis and that gives you P
plus Q here so you can follow that
recipe and it will it will give you an a
group law basically on on the points of
elliptic curve plus the point at
Infinity that you can't see on the plane
because it's Infinity so yeah that gives
you that gives you a group now the
isogenes the morphisms but between those
groups so let you know e and e Prime be
um be some um um elliptic curves then an
isogeny between them is a morphism uh
that has this form and what's
interesting about that
morphism is that knowing it's kernel is
essentially just as hard as calculating
it I mean I'm oversimplifying here but
that's really the key to um
understanding you know how those um
crypto crypto systems based on isogenes
work so they're going to basically when
you cook up isales what you do is in
fact you look at the subgroups of a
certain curve to choose a suitable
kernel okay so and of course yeah they
have degrees as well then these are
degrees of the of
the of the algebraic Maps
here
so okay so first of all let's um let's
see how a zero knowledge protocol could
be implemented with isogenes so Peggy
knows an isogeny between e and okay
every time you know C1 if C1 is the
konel of the isogen then the the the
curve that it maps to will be denoted e
quo C1 that means the Sal you obtain by
uh choosing the kernel C1 which is a
subgroup of e okay so Peggy knows an
isogen between two curves so those two
curves are public okay there are two
groups groups of points plus the point
at infinity and then Vic need needs to
be convinced that Peggy knows an isogen
between those two curves now telling Vic
what is the isogeny certainly sells down
I mean it sells it right but the problem
is we want to make a a zero knowledge
proof of that knowledge which means we
want to convince someone we know
something without actually revealing
what we know so
okay so Peggy publishes another curve so
here it's when you choose C2 another
kernel which gives you another morphism
to from E to another curve and E where
this time you quotient by you know the
the group generated by those two um so
that's a that's a third kernel okay okay
but you know knowing that knowing that
information about C1 and C2 gives you
also that information right C1 C2 so
Peggy knows all those curves and
obviously knowing all the the quotients
I mean sorry knowing all the kernels
Peggy would know how to calculate any of
of these isogenies going from here to
here from here to here from here to here
and from here to here now Vic is going
to challenge Peggy to give one of these
directions okay so Vic will flip a
coin and then if it's zero the she's
going to ask for which one is it for
zero so she's going to ask for the
morphism between e and C2 and
between oh that's it well okay oh sorry
no if it's zero then she's going to ask
for this morphism from E quo C2 to e quo
C1 C2
okay and then Peggy will give it to her
because she knows okay because she knows
all the directions and then if it's one
then she's going to ask for the two
vertical morphisms here and Peggy can
knowing all the kernels Peggy knows how
to produce those those morphisms now
what's important of course is to not
disclose any path that would go from E
to e Cent C1 so for example if you if
you publish both vertical and the
horizontal one then there going to be a
problem right because you don't want the
adverse you don't want Vic to be able to
learn the the path from E to e coent C1
because that's the the data you're
you're trying to protect okay and then
you repeat that protocol many times and
you know the chances of you being
successful not knowing not knowing that
direction e goes to e quo C1 well it's
it's essentially um it gets
exponentially bad after a few coin
tosses so that's one way of doing a an
misogyny protocol uh based on isogenes
sorry um zero knowledge protocol based
on isogenes now you can also do key
exchange based on the general philosophy
of of um of the D Helman problem so I
some of you guys are probably familiar
with the dman protocol you know Bob and
Alice
exchanging G to the A and G to the B and
that's that's familiar to everyone here
okay so this is going to be something
that looks a lot like Dy hman but it's
not quite Dy hman so they want to create
a chair secret that's always the same
setting for key
exchange okay and what they do is they
start from a curve e and then they they
have base points that are public P sub a
q sub a p subb q subb and then Alice is
going to use P sub A and Q sub a to
create a
kernel so that's a sub group that is
going to be generated by a certain
combination of PA and QA and then Bob is
going to use p subb and Q subb to create
another subgroup that you know generated
by some linear combinations of PB and
QB and then they're going to try to
exchange enough information for everyone
to land on the same curve at the of the
exchange and that curve will be the
secret so they draw m m na a okay and
then they compute a first isogeny okay
which they keep for themselves and each
isogeny corresponds to a kernel okay and
well then they send some of the images
so basically Alice with her uh secret
isogen first isogen F will send the
image of of the base points for Bob okay
which Republic and Bob does the same and
then they manag to each create a and I'm
going to have a little uh picture on the
next slide where it's a little more
visual but what happens here is that
both Alice and Bub will create a kernel
based on that that will combine that
information they will l in fact in the
same thing so they both have the same
asaly as the secret key so what it looks
like is like this so uh Alice
is that Alice yes that's Alice so Alice
looks at the kernel that's the group
generated by this secret Point here okay
and publishes this okay and goes to that
curve and Bob does the same okay so it
means that we have two curves at that
point but none of them is the
secret
then okay then Alice can use um Bob's 5B
of PA and sorry yeah 5bf PA and 5bf QA
to create another a a second isogeny
that goes in the same direction here you
know using using if you got you got to
make a good choice of Pas and and PBS
and qas and QBs and I'm not going there
but what happens is when Bob does the
exact same thing they both land on the
same curve here okay and that's really
how it works they've exchanged something
using their secret information
and no one that can actually um e drop
this conversation will be able to uh
figure out where they both landed but
they've yeah but they but they've
they've published those curves e es sub
A and Es sub B okay but no one knows
where they eventually
land so now here is how you can do a
little bit of um here's what we're going
to do to um solve that isogeny problem
so finding yeah maybe I should go back a
little bit if someone is suddenly
capable of finding isogenies between
curves then that gets a little um that
that can compromise this thing I mean I
don't want to get into the details of
how exactly because this the specific
scheme depends also on the degrees of
the isogenes that you're looking at so
it's not even clear if one isogen will
break everything with see isog to the
right degree but the bottom line is you
really don't want people to be good at
finding isogenes between two given
curves okay in this case you know if you
publish e todaa and then maybe it will
give you the secret and then you can
play Alice's role in this whole thing
and then land on the secrets so now
let's see how you can use a quantum
computer to compute
isogenes and let's see if it's if it's
actually
hard so we're going to need that ideal
class group that I didn't want to really
talk about before so ordinary curves and
that's when that's where ordinary and
and super singular curves they defer in
that sense is that the ordinary curves
their endomorphism ring so the Ring of
all the endomorphisms is isomorphic to
uh a certain ring within a quad
quadratic number field now we're going
to have to Define that object because
it's going to play a central role in the
evaluation of some isogenes between two
given curves so the ideal class group is
you look at the fractional ideals of
that ring and then you quotient by the
principal fraction ideas which really
means that every time you know an ideal
is equal to another one times a
principal Factor then you just identify
those ideal and that gives you that
group the class group is in fact a
finite group okay of a very large
carnality like when when the
discriminant goes to Infinity we're
we're talking about a really large group
here and the way this group relates to
the computation of isogenes is because
it acts on the isomorphism classes of of
elliptic curves whose endomorphism ring
is is isomorphic to to the ring here so
and and it acts via an isogenes so it
means that when you the action of of a
certain class of an ideal is made by an
isogeny of degree it's Norm so there's a
re there's a correspondence between
finding an isogeny say between uh E1 and
E2 and finding the right ideal that will
you know act on E1 and get you
E2 okay so that's that's why and that's
also what we're going to use for Quantum
algorithm
so um yeah
so that actually if I give you a the
ideal a we know how to compute it so and
I don't want to I realize that that's
going to be a little technical so I'm
going to Breeze through this just trust
me that we know how to do this okay if I
give you a we know how to uh take that
action like a star E1 and get E2 and the
way we do it is we have all sorts of
formulas let's just not talk about it
now knowing that we know how to do it
then it becomes our goal really if I
give you E1 and E2 what I really want if
I want to find an isogeny between E1 and
E2 what I want is to find that a and use
all the magic formulas that I have
working with a uh to calculate the
corresponding isogenies and the way the
way it's formulated in for as you look
at the function that takes classes of
ideals and and evaluate the action
of this class to um on a curve and the
thing is if you if I give you two curves
then those two functions will be a shift
of of one another so basically what I'm
saying is if E2 have an isogeny if it
there's an isogeny between E1 and E2
then I can take the function where I
have F sub1 and F sub E2 these are two
functions and I know how to evaluate
them and it turns out that I should be
able to notice when I evaluate them lot
that there there a shift from one
another and the corresponding shift is
exactly the the ideal a that acts on E1
and gives you E2 which I said is what I
want to find so and that there is an
algorithm the quantum algorithm that's
that's called the the hidden shift
problem and it's essentially essentially
boys down to Hidden subgroup problem in
a weird bizarre semi-direct product so
not a communative group and in
particular because it's not a
communative group it doesn't work as
well as the hidden subgroup problems
that we were talking in the previous in
the first part of the talk it's not
pomal time but it's still subexponential
which means that for example people were
not so happy about ordinary curves for
um you know using U uh isogen based
crypto
systems now they say well that's fine
let's go with super singular curve
so super singular curves their
endomorphism ring is a maximal order in
in in a in a algebra and in particular
not commutative so all the things that
we were mentioning before they don't
work now the question is of course is it
just because we get got rid of the
commutative property is that really a
problem or not
well what we found is that they are I
mean based on other people's work uh but
we adapted it for the quantum setting we
realized that in fact there are weak
instances in
particular the uh super singular curves
those that are defined over FP where p
is the characteristic of your field
these ones we were able to prove that in
fact you can reuse the trick for the
ordinary curves to build a Quantum I
mean to design a Quantum algorithms that
will find it in in goodish time I mean
it's
shortage time like like
subexponential so the main strategy is
to say well you're going to travel the
isogeny graph so you know try to find
your way isogeny by isogeny until you
reach a weak curve on both sides so you
want you want an misogyny between say um
e and e Prime and then first you travel
the graph of isogenes till you reach on
both sides the weak curves and then you
find an isogeny between those weak
curves
okay so turns
out the isogenic graph looks like this
you know you start from E and then you
travel and then every time you know it's
highly connected so you get lost very
quickly okay and the thing is you're
going to search for all the paths that
passes that pass through a curve defined
over FP and it's a search problem and
one of the magic of quantum algorithms
is that they can do search problem in in
time better than linear in the in the
size of the set through which there they
search so it's called Grover's algorithm
and what it does is if you're searching
a database of of length of of of size n
it'll find what you're looking for in
Time Square Root n even though the the
database is not ordered or anything of
course you know if you search through or
an an order list it's easy but if you
have no idea of any structure in your in
your database signs a little
mind-blowing that you can find something
in in time less than linear in the size
of that database okay here our database
is a is a set of of a lot of different
paths that you could take and you're
going to search through uh through this
for all those paths that that go through
a weak curve and then once you do that
well you can move on to the next stage
which is dealing with the weaking
instances so what's special about the
weak instances well their endomorphism
ring I mean their ring of endomorphisms
Define over FP has just the right
structure to use the trick that we were
you doing before for the ordinary curves
okay what it means is basically
everything I'm going to you know I'm
going to wave my hands I'm going to say
everything we did for the ordinary
curves you can do it for the weak super
singular curves once you found them in
the highly connected graph of isogenes
okay so because then you know you have
your nice commutative ring and
everything works just the same
way so what it means
is because of your
grzeda curves you know they're still
you're still shaving a factor two in the
exponent you go from o of P of the 1/2
to O of P of the 1/4 and if you happen
to look for an misogyny between weak
Curves in fact what's going to happen is
you have a subexponential time algorithm
so like a super poal
improvement over um the exponential time
algorithm okay so so that shows that you
know although although the super
singular curves although they have a
very different they work in a very
different way with their ring of
anamorphism being completely different
it's not completely guaranteed that
there's nothing you can say um so people
say oh you know they're so different
there's no way anything we do for
ordinary curves can can can can apply
what it's not it's not clear we should
scrutinize it more now um how much time
do I have uh because we started a little
late how what was the the plan I have
like a few more slides on totally I mean
not unrelated topic but um just
different so I could stop here or could
talk about what I'm going to say at the
qip ROM session which is I'm going to
talk about a super polinomial slowdown
on sh shes algorithm so making shes
algorithm
slower yeah it's meant to be a rum
session talk so here's the thing you
know uh you know to so the community is
like okay well let's U let's um you know
because of sh's algorithm we're forced
to look at alternatives to RSA you know
like lce based cryptography multivaried
cryptography code based isogen based you
name it now in Jo in joh work with Dan
Bernstein and Mikel and Moscow we have
an alternative strategy to uh solve this
problem of you know the the concerns of
the community with respect to schs
algorithm is to just make it slower okay
so let's see uh what we really mean by
that so poal time so shows algorithm
gives you solution poal time now the
best solution to um the the problem of
factoring n with classical computers is
um in uh subexponential time so
subexponential is defined by that funny
function here uh we call it
subexponential because when that first
parameter varies from one to zero you go
from something exponential to poal and
what whatever it's in between is called
subexponential okay and clearly if you
go from a subexponential algorith I mean
subex algorithm to poal time algorithm
this is what we call a super poal
Improvement it's not just shaving off a
factor in the exponent it's it's really
fundamentally faster okay now if you
want to slow down Shores maybe we should
use a little bit of the the the the the
method that's that that works slowly
classically okay
so what does how does it work like the
number field C for factoring uh RSA
integers in a nutshell the way works is
has many many many integers that you
need to factor and find those that can
be expressed as the product of primes
bounded by a certain bound okay so you
have
this very large number of smaller
integers than the one that you're trying
to factor and then you want to Factor
them all and keep those that are the the
the product of small primes and then you
do all sorts of abuse on those numbers
that I'm not even going to talk about
now our hybrid approach would be well
now how about using Shore not to factor
the big number but Factor the small
numbers and how about using Grover to
search through all the numbers and find
those that are products of because I
said Grover the grover searches this
magic trick where in instead of when you
when you search n and n elements then it
takes to square root n time so sounds a
pretty natural thing and it turns out
this is the runtime that we get okay um
so sub exponential still and then this
is second coefficient so what's what's
really that's so the objective is
attained in the sense that this is ASM
totically worse worse than than a
polinomial Time algorithm so that that
is the our our complexity and this is
the complexity of Show's algorithm so
clearly ours is much much worse however
this is a little bit concerning still
because that time is also ASM totically
better than the best uh ASM totic a
classical runtime so it outperforms
anything else that exists at the time
and also the number of
cubits is uh in our method is um
oh uh yeah sh so Shore's number of
cubits is is O of log n while ours is of
log n
2/3 and the number of cubits is in fact
very important when it comes down to uh
the feasibility of um of a quum
algorithm because it quantifies you know
like roughly speaking the size of a
computer you you you'll you you'll need
when it comes down to actually
implementing it so people are saying
well you know shows algorithm it's going
to take so many cubits AKA it's going to
it's going to it's going to require your
your computer to manage so much Quantum
information that we have so many years
before us before it actually you know
con computers actually make a difference
in factorization now what it says is
that well you know there are other ways
maybe not as efficient but it would
still make a difference because you know
it's it's ASM totically smaller and and
would require less cubits so well in
fact it's not that reassuring it's the
whole point that I was trying to make so
well thanks a lot for uh your attention
and the
[Applause]
invitation on the very last line that
you got there do you know anything about
the constants for the um the orders um
the uh log to the 2/3 cubits is that
really fewer cubits in practice or is it
just well okay that that is a there's
actually two questions in there so the
constant itself in what I meant here
actually from top of my head I can't
tell you but it's probably something
that could be worked out now it doesn't
necessarily tell you how many cubits you
actually need so this is a different and
that's a different problem is the
problems of of fault fault tolerant
fault tolerant implementation okay so
maybe I I think we could easily narrow
down the actual constant here for
example people have been also like um
figuring out the constant here in sh's
algorithm so used to be the like oh it's
going to be two times log in and now
people are like No in fact you can do
better you can have log in and we could
play the same kind of game and tell you
exactly which number here now that would
not necessarily tell you how many actual
Cubit you'll need for a fault tolerant
implementation and that depends on other
factors than our ability to count it's
the error correcting codes that are used
and so you got to make some yeah so I'm
I'm accustomed to telling people the
factor and N B integer you need two n
logical
cubits and 2 N minus one gets you
nowhere and what this is telling me is
that well maybe 2 N minus one you can do
something with and that's where the
constants come in sorry two can you
sorry you the the yeah if you factor in
all the the error correction um and you
get logical cuits as a result of this so
if you if you want to factor say a 20 48
bit integer you need
roughly you as of now sorry as of now
with the current stateof thee art you
would need with sure you need
496 logical or
4097 2 plus 3 these are logical still
log logical so I'm telling you that's
better than that there is a result where
they can actually get it to uh log in I
think there is another result based on D
simultaneous DTI equations so something
about DTI equations like I think someone
else like not shes paper but I think
there's another paper that gets it down
by Factor two okay so you can do this in
2048 I think so to be confirmed like I I
think I think I can't tell you from the
top of my head the the actual reference
but I think it's been improved by
someone okay the result over there
though um with in indate that for
sufficiently large n you can do even
better than that oh absolutely but two
things here the caveat is twofold first
of all um you can do better but at of at
the price of a worse Astic run time
that's one thing like G has to be
stressed but the other thing is that um
you got to look at default tolerance
implementation and the devil in the
details because it turns out that the
search circuit that goes through you
know a very large number of ends that
size of a circuit is
subexponential and the the for now the
best balance that we have for fault
throwing implementations they will be
proport like the the the they will
basically the the overhead will be
proportional to that okay now it's been
conject conjectured that there are
families of codes for which you you
don't have that bat of an overhead that
is directly proportional to the size of
the circuit okay but with the current
technology we only we're only showing a
better number of logical cubits if you
go to a f
implementation it will blow up because
the size of the circuit for sure is
smaller than the size of the circuit
that we're talking about here because of
the big search it's too big of a circuit
for the current technology in terms of
fault on
implementation okay thank you questions
I still don't get the Slowdown argument
what you basically said think if I
understood it right is instead of
running Shores algorithm directly you
can kind of run number field s where you
use other Quantum things for parts of it
and that doesn't run as fast as sure as
sure but it's faster as the but it's
faster than number field have done
completely classically yes okay so that
I
get but no one would do it that way if
they had access to upon a computer with
sufficient bits and with sufficient bits
that's yeah so then so then the only way
that you're getting a Slowdown is you're
trying to play off this small Delta here
in terms of the number of logical cubits
you need and you'd have to argue that
you would then have to size the the the
composite the public keys that you're
using an RSA so that it was basically
exceeded the number of Quantum that you
could build and run Shores on directly
but didn't exceed the log the 2/3 Factor
right I mean that's kind of what the
argument is right pretty
much basically it's it's an argument
about when when are going when are the K
computers going to make a difference
and there's an intermediate step that
can be taken that's kind of like what
we're saying yeah which is which is I
can take NFS and I can apply smaller
quantum computer hybrid technique will
will
well possibly would be feasible before
full-fledged
Shores uh implementation I
would I think that that positive
statement which is hey there's an
intermediate step here that we should be
aware
ofh is a better way to say what you just
pres but that's a rum session talk I
understand I understand it's talk you
start with a provocative title and I've
been down that path but I think there
that's what we wanted that's how we're
selling it for real okay fair enough
don't worry aware of that okay may that
far in Academia not by saying everything
is crap no but yeah that that's right
that's right important that's how that's
how we're phrasing it don't worry and
and well no I actually think that that
is an important statement because one of
the problems we're we're seeing it
exactly that way yeah
okay
so with the isogen systems uh I mean in
the classical case with RSA we're happy
with a subexponential
algorithm yes we be happy with the
ordinary curves if they would have an
advantage over super singular you mean
an advantage in ter in terms of uh
performance so if you tell you're
telling me I I reviewed the crypto
systems based on super singular curves
and ordinary curves I have a
mind-blowing implementation with
ordinary curves what do you make of
their
security um so it's only sub exponential
algorithms that we have now the question
is um well I think it's it's like it's
the thing about cryptography like some
of the stuff in cryptography is just a
little irrational this there that
component irrational component so RSA
has been studied for so long and it was
first to the market and and people are
people are happy with the l13
algorithm uh while with super singular
sorry with ordinary curve isogen you
only have a well one and a half with a
quantum computer which you know God
knows what it would look like for real a
quantum computer running something in
l12 but people don't like people really
want to see like for a new system it
looks like people want to see
exponential time everywhere the moment
you start to tell them that there's sub
expon especially if it hasn't been
studied for that long and suddenly so it
could be that sub SM is the best i1 have
is the best will ever do for ordinary
elliptic curves but since it came like
rather soon after it's been
described then people think oh come on
like you know like they almost think
that there's a curve of you know
complexity in time and you know if if if
we interpolate that curve and if you got
to l12 and so you know such a it doesn't
mean anything right it it's really a lot
of it in cryptography is is
psychological
so yeah there's no good answer to your
not not good nothing
scientifically uh
good okay
thanks thank
you